hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and he freaking
did it man horikoshi trolled the entire
mha community he pulled up bait and
switch and that massive ua trader reveal
from the previous week turned out to be
a fake reveal now the traitor was still
revealed in this latest chapter we know
who it is it was deku's mom obviously
but it is not who we were directly led
to believe it was at the end of chapter
335. okay for those of you who are new
to the channel i am kidding about deku's
mom but it is a class 1a student and i
will explain all of it in this video
needless to say this video will contain
massive boku no hero manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned now normally i do not make
videos based on manga spoilers which
come out earlier than the actual full
chapter normally i wait until the full
chapter drops before making any sort of
review but with the insanity of this
reveal and with how much it changes
everything we thought we knew from last
week i felt that i had to make this
video right now to clarify everything i
will still make a regular in-depth
review of the entire chapter once it
drops in a few days so definitely
subscribe to the channel and hit that
bell so you don't miss it that said in
this video i will be narrowly focusing
on the real traitor reveal how it all
fits into the story all the clues that
we had about the traitor's identity up
to this point and so on as you might
recall in my previous video where we all
thought that total was revealed as the
traitor i said this i mean the only way
that toru isn't the traitor now is if
horikoshi is deliberately tricking us
and then in the next chapter we see that
toto was actually being set up by
someone else like say deku's mom but
that's probably unlikely
so yes that probably unlikely thing
turned into definitely 100 percent fact
the real traitor is not toru hagakure
but rather yuga aoyama no twinkle boy no
the spoilers for chapter
336 reveal that toru had been shown in
the final panel of the previous chapter
not because she was the traitor but
because she had been keeping an eye on
aoyama unlike all the other students
aoyama has continued to be depressed
since the war arc ended and he seemed to
have gotten even worse since deku
returned to ua which is kind of the
opposite of everyone else's behavior
toro was worried about aoyama so she
went out in the forest to talk to him
but then she stumbled upon a private
conversation that aoyama was having with
his parents and of course his parents
were moved into the uh shelter along
with the families of the other ua
students during this conversation that
aoiyama and his parents believe is
private his parents tell him that he has
to keep obeying all for once orders and
he has to keep leaking information to
the villains aoyama is the traitor and
he has been working for all for one
because all for one threatened to kill
his parents if he didn't aoyama is the
real reason that the villains knew about
the location of the student training
camp about the usj and presumably other
important info as well however it is
clear that aoyama isn't doing these
things willingly he is being blackmailed
by all for one and the lives of his
parents are being threatened far from
being okay with all of this aoyama is
heartbroken and crying he doesn't want
to be the traitor and his parents also
don't like that their son is being
forced to do this but at the same time
they're telling him that he has to
continue in order to save all of their
lives based on the spoilers it seems
that aoyama's family first met all for
one when they went to him for help when
aoyama was still a child yuga aoyama was
actually born without a quirk he was
quirkless and this made him different
from everyone else it made him a social
outcast which is something that dec also
had to deal with throughout his
childhood aoyama felt that he had to
have a quirk if he wanted to achieve his
dream of becoming a hero so his parents
made a deal with all for one and all for
one transferred naval laser into aoyama
now it makes sense why aoyama struggled
so hard to control naval laser it was a
quirk that was not originally intended
for him so it was not compatible with
his body then deku arrives on the scene
since he also noticed that something was
up with aoyama and then he and toru both
confront aoyama about what they just
heard so many moments in which ayama's
behavior just seemed off and different
from the others now makes a lot more
sense this entire time aoyama was torn
between loyalty to his friends and
keeping his parents safe and he did
horrible things that put the lives of
his friends in danger in an attempt to
protect his family the chapter ends with
a sobbing aoyama telling deku that he is
a dirty villain absolutely unreal twist
especially after we were all so
convinced that it had to have been toru
i mean to be fair toru and aoyama were
definitely the two most popular suspects
but horikoshi really went out of his way
to make us think that it was toru in the
last chapter just so he can pull a
switcheroo in this new chapter the man
really is an absolute mad lad i have to
say that just over a month ago vocal
pineapple made a comprehensive video on
the aoyama is the traitor theory and a
lot of what was just revealed actually
confirmed things in that video including
the parents angle the fact that the
quirk doesn't fit his body and more i
will link the video down in the
description if you want to check it out
it's basically spot on now let's take a
quick look at the evidence that we had
about aoyama being the traitor before
this crazy twist much like toru his
exact location during the usj villain
attack is unknown and when asked about
it he outright refuses to say stating
that it's a secret aoyama has also been
acting weird and throwing odd knowing
glances at the audience and at deku for
a long time to the point that i thought
that he couldn't be the traitor since if
he really was then his behavior was
almost a little cheesy get it cheesy
anyway we were initially told that
aoyama was born with some sort of birth
defect that made it difficult for him to
control his own quirk the lasers which
shoot out from his navel would leak out
from his body uncontrollably which made
him a social outcast since everyone was
afraid that his quirk would hurt them
thankfully aoyama eventually received a
special belt which allowed him to
control his quirk but unlike most
supporting equipment this belt is not an
optional accessory aoyama has to wear it
all the time we now know the real reason
why aoyama was having so much trouble
controlling his quirk it wasn't his
quirk in the first place it was a quirk
stolen by all for one and then given to
him and he couldn't control it because
it wasn't a good fit for his body this
makes me wonder could naval laser
actually be a lot more powerful than we
realize but aoyama just hadn't been able
to unlock its full potential yet because
it wasn't compatible with his body could
haoyama one day undergo a quirk
awakening and naval laser becomes
something way way more powerful
it's interesting to think about the
aoyama traitor theory emphasized that
all for one and ujiko must have been
somehow involved in his life before he
came to ua either aoyama was born
quirkless and his quirk was given to him
by all for one which is why it doesn't
seem to be compatible with his body or
that belt that aoyama uses to control
his quirk was actually created by ujico
either way the theory stipulated that
aoyama and his parents were now indebted
to all for one and that is why aoyama
had to be the traitor additionally if
aoyama and his parents had contact with
over one in the past either regarding
his quirk or his belt that all for one
knows his parents and he could be
threatening them basically he could be
blackmailing aoyama into giving him
sensitive information about the ua and
threatening to hurt his parents if he
doesn't comply and this theory turned
out to be true aoiyama was born
quirkless he received his quirk from all
for one and this made his entire family
indebted to all for one on top of that
the villain is threatening to kill his
parents if he doesn't comply and
continue being a traitor unless
horikoshi decides to flip the script on
us again the aoyama trader theory as it
was outlined in the volkl pineapple
video is spot on please let me know what
you guys thought about this epic troll
from horikoshi are you happy that the
traitor was aoyama and not toru are you
disappointed do you still believe it's
actually deku's mom let me know down
below also how do you feel about the
fact that aoyama was an unwilling
traitor that he's essentially being
forced into doing this does this mean
that he can be redeemed and will he
maybe switch sides and help the heroes
feed false information to the villains
that concept about feeding false intel
to the villains could actually be a huge
deal for the heroes especially since we
now know from the last chapter that all
for one is going to start leaning on the
traitor for assistance very soon if the
traitor gives all for one false
information he could lure the villains
into a trap and it's game over all in
all this was absolutely insane horikoshi
really pulled one over on us i mean i
feel like there was no reason for toto
specifically to be involved in this
scene someone else could have been the
one to inform deku about aoyama's
conversation with his parents or deku
could have just stumbled upon it himself
i honestly feel that horikoshi included
toru in this scene just so he could end
the previous chapter the way he did and
stick it to everyone who thought that
the traitor had to be her all of these
years i wonder if horikoshi watched some
of the traitor theory videos on youtube
because he's definitely dunking on some
of us the mha manga is extremely intense
right now the traitor bait and switch is
going to have a massive impact on the
story and all the characters so i can't
wait to see what happens next don't
forget to leave your feedback down in
the comments below and of course if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more boku no hero content right here on
the channel just leave a quick like it
only takes a second but it helps a lot
with the youtube algorithm and if you're
new to the channel or maybe you watch
our videos but you just haven't taken
the time to subscribe yet do me a quick
favor and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all the notifications you
really have to go through the trouble of
subscribing hitting the bell and then
selecting that option that says all if
you don't do that you're still gonna
miss a ton of our videos even if you are
subscribed it's just how youtube works
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram
uproar
at
want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime opera patrons who make videos
like this one possible special thank you
to alpha sigma this man is an absolute
mad lad and a disciple of lord twego
himself and i can't forget all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who stand
above all other clans including ingrata
algital pate heffa the red-haired fox
hinokamian water the toasted chi corey
mcgowan the spike dylan isidor spidey
life tinel tungsten tarkis baked
buddhist monkey d quilly cody hebert and
jeremy cummings finally thank you also
to our pro hero tier patrons including
the one and only gilgamesh steelers
angel cruz very gucci alicia octor
bonnie parks joy and garcia fat boy
games kaido might be a duck jessica
rabbit and jeremy phillips if you enjoy
our videos and you feel that they
provide value to you consider supporting
us on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these legendary people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you